well rescue helicopters are flying all
over the Carolinas to help evacuate
flood flood victims the Coast Guard says
it has rescued 133 people in just the
last 72 hours 67 of them were pulled up
yesterday alone
mark Strassmann is in Elizabeth City Air
Station in North Carolina the largest
Coast Guard Air Station in the country
mark good morning good morning this is a
Jayhawk rescue helicopter it's the
biggest one the Coast Guard has and the
Coast Guard now has personnel from five
different states helping out with the
different rescue operations here once
the weather improved on Saturday these
flight crews have had their hands full
24 hours a day
rescue crews but the US Coast Guard have
flown in and out of the storm shifting
flood zone and all weekend CBS News has
watched them bring as many trapped
people to safety as possible body camera
video shows one rescue swimmer lower
toward a home surrounded by rising
floodwaters there the swimmer helped
evacuate an elderly woman who's
medication had run out this is called a
Stokes litter it's the basket that the
helicopter lowers to rescue people
sometimes it's 30 feet sometimes it's
200 feet one two or three people if
they're small can fit inside this basket
and they're hoisted up to this
helicopter on Sunday a single flight
crew evacuated this neighborhood in
Rocky Point rescuing 26 adults 11
children 7 dogs and four cats in a
single day these are people's houses and
and and they're underwater
lieutenant Matt Dillahunty is a Coast
Guard helicopter pilot do you ever get
used to seeing these neighborhoods in
this kind of condition no no it's just
not natural
I mean you're never gonna get used to
seeing American neighborhoods underwater
trucks flipped over underwater we can
only see the tailgate and the the
emergency blinkers watching I mean you
just never get used to it the Coast
Guard rescued 57 people on Saturday 67
people on Sunday and with ongoing
threats from cresting rivers and flash
flooding they expect another busy day
today John Thank You Marco amazing views